Out of fake gods and bad gods and demi-gods
and would-be gods.
Out of the whole pantheon, which god makes
societies better?
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
Recently the idea that belief in one “big
god” lead to the rise of complex societies
held sway in research circles.
But that’s being challenged by new research
published in the journal Proceedings of the
Royal Society B.[1]
So this is a story of different types of religion,
there’s more monotheistic religions with
a “Moralizing High God” or one supreme
being that hands out morality and punishment,
and religions that have “Broad Supernatural
Punishment”, which can be loosely polytheistic,
meaning many gods and includes things like
ancestral spirits and concepts like karma.
Previous research showed that belief in a
“Moralizing High God (MHG)” allowed societies
to become more politically sophisticated.
This research seems to refute that.
It showed that religions with multiple deities
or spirits or karma type punishments lead
to more complex societies, but religions with
one “head honcho” did not.
But how does a belief in any kind of religion
build complex societies?
Well thinking you’re gonna be punished if
you do something wrong, even if no one is
looking, is a pretty good deterrent or it
might make us more likely to cooperate.
One study published in the Journal of Personality
and Social Psychology showed that people become
less hostile in a threatening situation when
they’re reminded of their religious beliefs.
This is especially important when life gets
tough.
[2]
Another study published in the Proceedings
of the National Academy of Sciences found
that those who live in harsh environments
tend to believe in “big Gods”.
They think these beliefs drive people to be
more pro-social when conditions make it hard
to survive.
Cooperation, even if it’s costly to the
individual, could enable a group to thrive
in times of stress.[3]
But it seemed like an age old tale of correlation
not causation.
Some studies show it’s the other way around,
as societies get more complex they're more
likely to have one central guy in the sky.
One study published in the journal Current
Biology found that as a society became more
affluent, it triggered more moralizing types
of religions.
[4]
Which gets us back to the most recent research.
So, the team of researchers of various Australian
institutions looked at 96 Asian Pacific cultures,
because these Austronesian cultures are well
documented and less influenced by main single
deity religions like Christianity and Islam.
They found that belief in a head honcho deity
did not drive or sustain the evolution of
political complexity, but rather it tends
to come along for the ride.
The research also suggests that it’s belief
in broad supernatural entities like ancestral
spirits or karma actually smoothed the way
for cultures to become complex.
And that makes sense, just look at history,
there’s plenty of examples of cultures without
High Moralizing Gods, like the Greeks and
Romans and Mayans, who built incredibly sophisticated
societies.
Maybe because of the cooperative motives I
mentioned earlier or maybe not so nobly, the
supernatural gives more weight to your claim
to authority and power.
If you say you’re in contact with these
gods, or that these gods are your ancestors,
people are gonna believe you and maybe follow
you.
So this research is still in it’s early
stage and clearly needs more study.
And it’s not like you have to be religious
to have a complex cooperative society anyway.
Other studies show that "Some of the most
cooperative modern societies are also the
most secular".[5]
But how does this new research make you feel
about the role of religion in society?
Let us know in the comments below.
And don’t forget to hit those like and subscribe
buttons and keep coming back for new episodes
every day of the week.